let me talk about the centrality of
energy I want to talk with you about
energy and sustainability management and
again just as I have in the other
chapters in the book when I talk about
at first I talk about the technical
technological challenges what are the
technologies that we have to focus on
then there's the issue of finance and
all of this new technology and
infrastructure costs money so where is
it going to come from the fourth issue
is the issue of organizational capacity
if we have the technology and we have
the money we still have to have the
capacity the train people to know how to
do this in enough places and finally
what's the role of government and public
policy to bring this all about faster
than the market will bring it about on
its own now there are people who will
tell you well the automobile didn't need
government intervention nonsense who do
you think built the roads where the
money come from for the roads it was
taxes on gasoline wasn't by magic who
put in the traffic lights ok same
government not magic who hired the cops
to give out the traffic tickets when
people were driving too fast or crossing
the red lights without stopping it's
this idea that you hear over and over
again that government doesn't play a
role in the development of private
enterprise appear in the United States
is ludicrous it really needs to be
dismissed it's an ideological artifact
of a previous time that never was even
true then government has always played a
role in economic development so does the
private sector and so here's a little
secret I'll say this a number of times a
semester the war between the Communists
and the capitalist is over and both won
because we actually need the free
enterprise system to create wealth and
to motivate people and we need
government to make sure that we don't
kill ourselves off in the competition
for wealth and to stimulate new
technologies and make them happen so
let's talk about energy and
sustainability management the heart of
the sustainability issue is energy and I
really believe this very strongly unless
we depend our dependence on fossil fuel
we cannot develop a long-term
sustainable economy now one of the one
of the students mentioned to me that's
true that there's a lot of new natural
gas coming online and it's very
inexpensive and it's it can be less
polluting but it also is a hydrocarbon
it also in its a certain amount of
carbon dioxide to other greenhouse gases
and it is also finite there may be a
hundred or two hundred years of this
stuff around but it that's not forever
and if we can think of and getting it
out of the ground is not always
cost-free environmentally and so we need
to think about another energy paths but
we need to worry about the fossil fuels
emissions we need to worry about the
environmental damage of extraction the
Gulf oil spill is an example of that
there's lots of other examples of it
when you host fossil fuels out of the
ground it doesn't do good things to the
ground you know it's not so good for the
fish and the other aquatic life in the
Gulf of Mexico right now nor will it be
for awhile the other thing is pure
economic supply and demand and again
it's not going to happen in your
lifetime but it's true that these fuels
are finite as they get more scarce their
price will go up since the Sun and
nuclear power or other kinds of
high-tech solutions will not necessarily
get more expensive as time goes on they
can actually get less expensive what you
want to do is get on the same cost curve
that computing has gotten on whereas you
apply new technology it gets cheaper and
cheaper to get more and more of the
technology deliver some kinds of
technologies will develop over time and
prices where again natural resources on
this planet are never going to expand
now someday maybe we'll be on other
planets but we haven't figured it out
yet so if we can develop low-cost
renewable energy we can overcome many of
the constraints on economic development
and go a long way to solving the
sustainability problem now why is it so
important it's important to this modern
life requires energy you know this idea
that we're going to sit alone in the
dark and the cold in the winter and the
heat in the summer and do nothing and
that's going to be a sustainable
economic life for us as nonsense people
won't accept it it would be politically
destabilizing we like the lights TV the
ipods the climate control all that other
stuff and everybody else in the world
that gets exposed to it likes it and
there's a reason for it it makes our
lives more comfortable and more
interesting okay it's not a mystery it's
a fundamental fact what is less well
recognized I think is that our system
for growing delivering food and
distributing water also requires massive
amounts of energy there are fewer than
1% of the population the united states
involved in delivering and growing food
for us now down from about forty percent
at the beginning of the 20th century and
what we've done is we've replaced human
labor and energy with artificial
mechanized labor and energy massive
energy use those huge tractors are
replacing lots and lots of animals and
people that used to toil in the fields
and they're much more efficient and they
produce a whole lot more food so if we
solve the energy problem we solve the
sustainability problem now I admit I
have a bias towards solar energy i
believe it's the transformative
technological fix I don't dismiss the
idea of nuclear but I think you have to
have a nuclear that doesn't produce
waste and doesn't potentially produce
material that can be
used in bombs so you need a different
kind of nuclear power now one of the
problems with nuclear power as we use it
in the world is that after the
devastation of World War tues to nuclear
explosions Dwight Eisenhower and other
people in the United States decided to
do something called atoms for peace they
wanted to show that this technology
would not just destroy cities but could
also be used for good and we could have
electricity which they said at that time
would be quote too cheap to meter
unfortunately it didn't work out that
way so I believe that solar power is a
more accessible form but I won't dismiss
the idea of nuclear power if we could
overcome the current problems with it
but we need low cost less
capital-intensive decentralized and less
polluting entry now those are all
different things low cost I want it to
be cheap less capital-intensive meaning
solutions that don't require massive
infrastructure interventions like the
Bogota subway system oh it's a bus
system okay we didn't have to dig we
didn't have to spend fortunes of money
digging up the city we just figured out
a clever way of getting around that
constraint decentralized meaning that if
we can create something that's less
capital-intensive and small-scale if you
could generate all the power you needed
for your home inside your home that
would be a pretty nice low capital
potentially decentralized strategy
wouldn't that be nice what do you think
the electric utilities would say if you
started doing that it would be like you
know the Roger Rabbit movie only for
electricity so what's the technological
challenge of energy the technological
challenge is that the US energy system
is characterized by large scale capital
intensive centralized facilities so I'm
calling for the opposite of that small
scale less capital-intensive and
decentralize so that's what I'd like to
see I don't know if it's feasible but
that's what I'd like to see electricity
currently is generated by coal for the
most part in the United States other
fossil fuels sub-nuclear a little bit of
hydro power transmitted largely through
a very complicated and antiquated grid
system that were hopefully going to
modernize transportation is less
centralized through local gasoline
distribution but still has huge
infrastructure needs and roads now other
nations like France I mean over I think
75 percent of the energy and France is
generated by nuclear and so it is
possible to think about other
technological basis the reason we don't
have that in this country is more
political than anything else which is to
say that France has a highly centralized
form of government we have a very
decentralized form of government where
local state states and local governments
have enormous power particularly to veto
land uses and nobody after a certain
point one of one of these nuclear power
plants next door in fact in Long Island
we built wanna chore them and we
decommissioned it and people in Long
Island are still paying the capital
costs of that power plant which is never
generated any electricity whatsoever has
closed down due to political opposition
what are the technical issues how do we
develop renewable energy sources that
are clean and cost-effective when
compared to fossil fuels can we develop
a small low-cost solar cell and a
battery for storing electricity once we
generate it now here's what's
interesting about this and I use this
example a lot when I talk about solar
when I was in graduate school I used a
computer that was about I don't know a
quarter the size of this room and had
less computing power than this okay the
mainframes in the 1970s were the best we
had at that time I used to go to the
computer center at three in the morning
with my punch cards and try to get a day
to run brought back to me within two
hours that today you could do in a
couple of keystrokes on your laptop and
get your output in about a half a second
okay now that's the technology in about
30 years
of development of computing technology
so today a solar array is thirty
thousand dollars and sits on your
rooftop and they're pretty big sort of
like the old mainframes okay what if the
solar cell that the solar array that you
used 20 years from now with the size of
a window pane and the battery you had
could store the electricity in that
solar cell to power your old house all
the time rain or shine okay is it
unimaginable of course it's not it could
be done okay and if it was done you
would have a decentralized less
capital-intensive a form of energy now
if you had talked about computing power
to academic in the 1970s you would have
assumed that for typical computing uses
you would need highly centralized
capital intensive computing facilities
with lots of guys with white coats in
clean rooms making sure that the
computer was kept perfectly at 50
degrees a Fahrenheit so that the tubes
and the other parts and it wouldn't burn
up okay so what about could it be done I
don't know I'm a political scientist so
I'm just imagining this but the point
that I'm making is that technological
developments can be directed and can be
shaped by incentives if I were Barack
Obama if I were the in charge of the
department of energy that would be the
technological innovation i would put as
much resource in as possible because it
would be transformative it would be like
the cell phone it would be like the the
the internet it would be a tremendous
technological advance so that's one
question the other question is can we
develop a waste-free and less
capital-intensive form of nuclear power
well we could I mean that's another
avenue that we could follow to generate
power maybe not within the household but
maybe within the district what if the
what if you had every neighborhood in
New York City all 59 commute
boards had a little power plant a little
waste-to-energy plant took care of all
of its garbage and all of its energy
needs inside a building the same size as
the you know a small pumping station for
the water system you know we could even
make it look nice and open up a cafe
outside of it right the next question
how do we make the transmission process
smarter and more efficient and more open
to decentralize transmission we know
that we can do that the technology's
there now can we learn to collect and
store the carbon dioxide from fossil
fuels that will continue to burn my
friend class Lochner says he's a
professor in the engineering school that
we use more stones today than we use
during the Stone Age we use more wood
for fuel today than when wood was the
main source of fuel and he says we'll
use more fossil fuels in the future than
we use today so even as we make this
transition to other sources of energy
and all likelihood we're going to
continue to burn this stuff for a while
and we already have an accumulation of
carbon dioxide and other greenhouse
gases in the outer atmosphere and Klaus
and his colleagues are developing
technology to suck the carbon dioxide
out of the air and store it underground
or use it for productive purposes and so
that's another technology of that is a
challenge but is one that's required to
deal with the energy issue ok so that's
the technology let's turn to the dollars
how do we pay for all this I think the
climate and energy policy can modernize
our economies technological base and
ultimately increase our standard of
living now this is an interesting thing
there's always been this idea that
somehow if we impose new technologies
through regulation it will increase our
costs and make us poor and decrease our
standard of living nothing since 1970
when we started regulating the
environment in earnest in America bears
that at every single technology that
we've imposed air pollution technology
water pollution technology
catalytic converters on cars everything
else that we've done none of it has had
the impact on the economy the people
said it would have okay why because
these technologies end up providing
benefits that people often don't predict
and one of the benefits is actually that
we're healthier you know the the air and
water is healthier than it used to be
and so and we're able to attract people
to live here because of that so our goal
in the energy side should be to reduce
the percentage of our gross domestic
product devoted to energy expenditures
now this is the fundamental number that
we should be keeping our eye on when you
talk about wealth generation you look at
the input side the throughput and the
output of production in the system
energy like labor is an input into our
gross domestic product in nineteen
seventy eight percent of our gdp went to
energy to fuel the economy that grew to
thirteen point seven percent by 1981 and
then because the economy was growing
rapidly and the price of fossil fuels
was dropping rapidly it actually went
down to six percent in 1999 went back up
to seven percent by 2000 by 2006 the
last year I have data for it went up to
eight point eight percent what I've
heard is this is approaching ten percent
today okay although I don't have data on
that this is the hard data that I have
available to me so what does that mean
it means that if we want to get back to
1990s kind of wealth one way to do that
is to start working on this percentage
and you can do that in a number of ways
in your equation you can grow the
economy which helps you can lower fuel
costs which is another help if you
increase the mix of low-cost renewable
energy into your mix you may in fact
reduce this GDP number fossil fuels will
continue to get more difficult and more
expensive to extract and the long-term
cost of renewable energy and energy
efficiency are lower than those of
fossil fuels and wasteful energy
practice and this is the other issue
energy efficiency we waste about a third
of the energy we use in America from the
time it gets into our house this doesn't
include transmission ways within our
households and commercial establishments
we the low-hanging fruit of the climate
crisis is energy efficiency you know
think about it you go to a hotel in
Latin America or in Europe and you walk
out of your hotel room or in Asia you
walk out of your hotel room with your
key and the lights go off okay we don't
have those in America why do we not know
how to turn off lights okay a very
simple technology go to a hallway with
motion detectors lights come on when
you're there they go off when you're not
there on and on and on of different
kinds of technologies as energy
efficiencies become more and more of a
parameter in the design of refrigerators
and air conditioners they go down
rapidly in their use of energy today's
air conditioners use considerably less
energy than air conditioners used a
decade ago in fact the argument is if
you have an old air conditioner you
replace it with a new one a couple of
summers you paid for it and reduced
energy costs okay so energy efficiency
is clearly one thing that we need to do
now renewable energy requires capital
and it's going to involve higher costs
in the short and long term and middle
term but in the long term will reduce
costs now in New York and in California
right now every kilowatt-hour of
electricity has a surcharge on it in in
California it generates over a billion
dollars a year in New York State it
generates about a half billion dollars a
year which goes back into projects in
California the utilities distributed
mentally to consulting firms in New York
nyserda gets most of it but coned gets
some of it and it goes to projects that
come to the commercial small commercial
and household level to try to generate
energy efficiency that's something that
we can do easily but financing renewable
energy is a more complex problem the
problem is fossil fuel prices are low
and they don't include the price of the
external damage that fossil fuels create
renewable energy
are typically smaller and also have new
technology there's a problem in
financing new technology because the
investor doesn't understand the
technology doesn't have faith in it and
doesn't want to invest their scarce
capital remember capital goes after the
highest rate of return it's like you
know gravity and a river the water flows
to the look to the lowest point in this
case it flows to the point of highest
return so new technology is often
something that only a very brave
investor will put their money into and
so that becomes a problem for the
finance side the the absence of accurate
and standardized information about
renewable energy projects is a barrier
to the growth of capital we we don't
collect good information on the
technologies or the rate of return now
there's a lot of talk about a tax on
carbon by raising the price of fossil
fuels to make it possible for renewables
to become more competitive I'm convinced
now that that's the wrong approach I
don't think we should try to raise the
price of fossil fuels I think which use
government intervention to lower the
cost of renewable one of the students
here before mentioned rather than taxing
the old stuff let's incentivize the new
stuff and create an incentive by
bringing the price down so that's the
kind of thing that I think is possible
but again we're in a recession right now
even though technically we're not I mean
they say the economy has been growing
but unemployment has been hasn't been
coming down capital availability is
certainly not the way it was a couple of
years ago and so financing something
speculative like renewable energy is
difficult during this time period let me
turn to organizational capacity and here
it's having the technical capacity to do
the energy efficiency projects to
install the renewable energy
technologies to take the more
cost-effective furnaces and install them
and if somebody is used to installing
the old stuff they have to be trained to
install the new stuff it's not rocket
science
but it is a technological change I mean
this happens to people that maintain
orders we heard about this during
looking into the the new york city
transportation case earlier tonight that
teaching people to work on hybrid
engines is different than a pure
internal combustion engine you have to
figure out a way to do that the knee
there's really need for much more
skilled labor in solar and wind and that
has to be developed there are a number
of companies that are building energy
efficiency services there's one type of
company called the energy service
company or ESCOs and what enesco does is
they will do an energy audit find some
low-hanging fruit lend the person the
Capitol or the industry the capital to
make the change and take their payments
on the reduced energy costs and it's a
complicated scheme but it does work one
of the problems with escos is that
sometimes their financial interests are
not the same as their clients interest
their job is to make money on your
energy savings so they may propose
things that are not as in your interest
as you might want them to be because
they're lending you the money you know
always beware of people that bring you
capital and say that it's free okay
anybody that brings you capital and says
it's free is not entirely being it's not
being entirely honest there's always a
cost to it but it might be in your
interest if your interest line up with
the ESCOs interest than it's worth doing
it that way ESCOs can help small
businesses that don't have sufficient
capital and they can work to ensure that
energy efficiency projects generate
short term savings because that's how
they make money but it will constrain
the types of projects that they'll
propose because they're interested and
making their money back and getting out
the shorter the turnaround time the
better and that may not be the best
thing for you and your business
organizations that are involved in the
renewable energy business tend to be
under resourced right now it's an
emerging industry with no clear leaders
that may change you do see a lot of the
fossil fuel companies like she'll and
others getting into this business but
they're not there yet we need staff
there's
killed in these new technologies but you
know it's not going to be easy and then
of course there are political problems
of citing a wind farm off the coast of
sane and tuck it isn't that easy because
I understand the Kennedy family in
particularly doesn't like their view to
be obstructed they've lived out there
for a while and when they go to the
shoreline they don't want to see
windmills they want to see seagulls and
you know and vistas and so that's a
problem let's talk about government and
public policy now government has played
a role in the energy business for a very
long time first gas and electricity
generators I mean in New York City coned
I mean the aid was Edison Thomas Edison
the guy that invented this thing called
power generation and that utility was
formed by getting a monopoly initially
from the city of New York to distribute
and generate electricity and so the
energy industry has always been
regulated has always been involved with
government the public utility
commissioners public service
Commission's around the country have
long been involved in regulating the
rate of turn because if you know it
makes no sense to have ten different
electric companies operating in one
place now a number of years ago we
separated the energy generation and
distribution business but they're still
essentially regulated monopolies and one
of the obstacles to decentralize
renewable energy is there are many
different rules governing access to the
power grid there may be a favorable rule
in one place a very difficult and
inaccessible grid in another place and
clearly as we one of the things that
government can do is invest in smart
grid technology that allows for
decentralized energy and that really
will be one of the most important
government policies it's it's very
similar in energy terms to building the
interstate highway system in the 1950s
and 60s we need to have that kind of
technological change
in our power generation so we need that
we do have a growing set of policies in
place to develop and promote energy
efficiency that part of the policy
equation is pretty non-controversial why
even the first of all they made it in
the interested electric utilities to
promote this coned does not make its
money on how much more electricity
generates it's a fairly complicated
equation but if they can save per capita
use of energy they get rewarded by a
bonus on their rate and so that becomes
part of their incentive to promote
energy and efficiency it's hard to argue
against what's the argument against
energy efficiency we should waste as
much as possible we should spend more
money on energy instead of becoming a
more efficient economy that part of the
policy equation hasn't been too
problematic policies have been set to
require buildings vehicles and
appliances to meet energy efficiency
standards that's government regulation
programs are funded by surcharges on
utility bills and they have increasingly
encouraged best management practices in
the case of renewable energy tax credits
are used to encourage development and
the use of renewable energy facilities
we can use the tax system to make those
risky investments pay off faster and
capital in two of those uses you can use
things like the municipal bond market
where the interest is tax free to the
recipient who's benefiting from that to
encourage more investment in these kinds
of technologies accelerating the use of
renewable energy is going to require a
lot of government activity government
has to fund the basic research and
development government money has to go
into that low cost solar cell that small
solar cell and that battery because the
private sector doesn't have the
resources and won't spend the money for
something with that long a turnaround
time government has to alter the cost
advantage of fossil fuels but again my
own view of it is not by raising the
cost of fossil fuels but by lowering the
cost of renewable energy now that's
not an accepted part of economic wisdom
but I think that is something that we're
going to see a change because the
because raising the price of fossil
fuels just seems to be too hard and with
the increased natural gas availability I
think it's really not going to happen
organized momentum entrenched interests
and institutional inertia makes it
difficult to transition from fossil
fuels to renewables there's a lot of
vested interests every gasoline station
owner in America is a vested interest
promoting fossil fuel use all the people
that operate and owned all that
infrastructure you know are going to
resist anything new coming in and so
there's also lots of money in fossil
fuels the you know these BP and shell
and so on ExxonMobil they make a lot of
money and they have a lot of political
power and so if there's going to be
changed here it's going to only be
because there's a counter force in
society that pushes it through the
political process so government has to
use the tax system to encourage
investment in renewables and to try to
provide access to lower-cost capital and
to try to encourage entrepreneurs to put
their capital into renewable energy so
let me conclude the transition from
fossil fuels is the most important
element of a sustainable economy and
planet this is the heart of the issue in
the u.s. it's going to take a major
effort by government and a real
partnership with the private sector and
I should mention the US isn't alone in
this Europe is working on this China is
working on this you're seeing this in
Latin America all over the world this
technology is being worked on and people
are paying attention to this changeover
but if you solve the energy problem you
solve the water problem because you can
desalinate and transport water wherever
you need it you solve the food problem
because food basically needs water and
nitrogen and those things can be solved
by solving the energy problem and of
course climate change and ecosystem
destruction is all helped by solving the
energy problem